J'ai fait aussi vite que j'ai pu...
L'espoir est-il encore permis, mon père ?
Malheureusement, non.
Comme vous le savez, il a survécu mais...
Le coup qu'il a pris sur la tête lui a fait perdre la raison.
Seigneur...
Sans Tristan nous sommes perdus.
Toutes nos dernières batailles ont été gagnées grâce à ses prédictions.
Lui ?
Il y a deux ans, il nous empêcha de tomber
dans l'embuscade des barbares en contournant le fleuve.
Il a un don.
Il avait, mon fils.
Parce que là, vraiment...
Il est cuit.
Attendez.
Qui nous dit qu'il ne tente pas justement de communiquer avec nous ?
Et bien, le fait qu'il ne communique pas avec nous.
Regardez !
C'est le signe des vieux pêcheurs.
Ça veut peut-être dire qu'il faut passer par les côtes.
Oui, je reconnais bien là Tristan.
Alors moi j'aurai plutôt compris qu'il a besoin d'un mouchoir...
Comme quoi c'est peut-être juste une question d'interprétation, mon fils.
Père Gaspard vous ne comprenez pas.
Il est en train de lire l'avenir.
Continuez Tristan, nous avons besoin de vous.
Et donc là, ça veut dire quoi ?
Une terrible maladie va décimer notre peuple.
Moi je vois juste un taré.
Notre civilisation va découvrir un nouveau continent !
Un taré, toujours.
Serait-ce... un nouveau moyen de se défendre ?
Une nouvelle arme !
Ou un taré.
Enfin je... Je campe sur mes positions, personnellement.
Serait-ce un royaume qui…
Ou l’apparition d’une activité populaire ?
Un nouveau sport peut-être !
Ashéa Assahéa imi ausséhoum…
Ça veut dire “taré” en Elfique.
Comme j'avais déjà dit trois fois pareil,
je tentais une petite variante.
Une... Une sorte de joute ?
Qui opposerait les… Les paysans à...
Non vous avez raison, il est complètement taré.
L’amour que je porte pour cet homme m’a aveuglé, là est la vérité.
Je ne peux voir un homme de ce rang dans un cet état plus longtemps.
Combien de temps lui reste-t-il ?
Bah là si je le soigne pas il passe pas la nuit.
Faites donc ainsi.
Très bien.
C’est peut être une danse en fait...
Vous êtes partis ?
Bon. Parce que c’est pas mal rythmé.